[موسيقى]
قلق دولي من تنامي قدرات الميليشيات
الحوثيه والمخاوف تتصاعد في باب المندب
[موسيقى]
قدرته العسكريه بصفقات روسيه
الى الطاوله
معكم في حلقه اليوم اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
اليابان والهند تختتمان اول مناورات
عسكريه مشتركه بينهما التدريبات التي
استمرت لاحدى عشر يوما شمال شرق العاصمه
طوكيو شاركت فيها مقاتلات من طراز اف 2
واف 15 اليابانيه هذا بجانب مقاتلات سوخوي
30 ام كي اي التابعه للقوات الجويه
الهنديه هذا طبعا الى جانب طائرات للنقل
من طراز سي 7 وتعد الهند هي خامس دوله الى
جانب الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
واستراليا والمانيا تجري مثل هذه
التدريبات القتاليه الجويه الثنائيه
معاليتها
[موسيقى]
في احدث خطوات الجيش البريطاني في مشروعه
الهادف الى الجمع بين الاله والبشره
بريطانيا تتعاقد مع شركه البيت سيستمز
الاسرائيليه لشراء مسيرات مبني اكس حيث
سيتم تجهيزها بانظمه بكاميرات كهروضوئيه
وكاميرات تعمل بالاشعه تحت الحمراء لدعم
مهام الاستطلاع المكثفاء ومن المقرر ان
يقوم فرع المملكه المتحده لشركه
الاسرائيليه بتسليم المسيارات بحلول العام
الجاري
ضمن جهوده لتوسيع اصول المركبات المدرعه
وزياده قدرته البحريه الجيش الايطالي
وقعوا صفقه مع شركه ايفيكو الايطاليه
للمركبات البرمائيه وكذلك بشراء 36 مركبه
برمائيه للسياحه البحريه من المتوقع ان
تزداد تعاقدات الجيش الايطاليه على هذه
المركبه خلال الفتره القادمه لتصل الى 164
مضيق باب المندب هو واحد من اهم خطوط
النقل بين مختلف القارات ممرنا اي يصل
البحر الاحمر بخليج عدن وبحر العرب مؤخرا
ابدت الكثير من الاوساط الدوليه قلقها من
امتلاك الميليشيات الحوثيه لقدرات تهدد
الملاحه البحريه في المضيق وكذلك في البحر
الاحمر خاصه بعد استخدام الميليشيات زوارق
مسيره مفخخه وايضا صواريخ مضاده للسفن
لمهاجمه السفن في السابقه المحلل السابق
في الاستخبارات العسكريه البريطانيه مارتن
كيلي هو احد المراقبين الذين يتوقعون
تصاعد التهديد للملاحه في باب المندب كيلي
يعمل حاليا كمحلل الاستخبارات في مركز
الاستشارات الامنيه في لندن وينضم الينا
الان لمناقشه هذه التوقعات اولا ان مصر
مارتن اهلا بك معنا في عسكريتاريا على اي
شيء تبني هذه التوقعات المتعلقه بتصعد
التهديدات الملاحه في مضيق باب المندب
خلال المرحله القادمه
زاد الحوثيون من خطابهم التهديدي
والرغبه في شم الهجمه في المجال البحريه
اليمني من ضمنها هجمه ضد خفر السواحل
اليمني وضد السفن التي يتهممها الحوثيون
بسبب النفط اليمني الى جانبه هجمات على
البناء التحتيه لمرافق الجنوب لقد حذر
الحوثيون مؤخرا من اندلاع مواجهه مع
التحالف على الجبهه البحريه واعلن ان امن
المناطق البحريه اليمنيه سيكون اولويتهم
في المرحله المقبله موشرين بذلك الى مضيق
باب المندب وخليج عدن ومياه سقطر
الاقليميه ومن الجدير بالذكر هنا انه من
غير المرشح ان يقوم الحوثيون بمهاجمه
السفن غير المنخرطه في النزاع او تلك التي
تحاول تصدير النفق من الموانئ التي لا
يسيرون عليها ومع ذلك يبقى احتمال ارتكاب
خطا في تحديد هويه السفن والاخطاء
الحسابيه قائما امم مستر مارتن فيما يتعلق
بالتهديد الاكبر هل تعتقد بانه سيكون
التهديد الاكبر هي الصواريخ المضاده للسفن
ام من قبل المسيررات
اطلاق الصواريخ من صنعاء هبطت في المياه
الدوليه
والحوثيون معروفون باستخدامهم تشكيله
واسعه من المسيرات الجويه والبحريه
فالتهديد قد يكون مصدره اي من المصادر
اعلاه
مستر مارتن هناك الكثير من الوحدات الان
تحاول الحفاظ على امن الملاحه سواء في
البحر الاحمر او حتى في مضيق باب المندب
ومنها وحدات تابعه للقياده المركزيه
الامريكيه برايك هل هذه الوحدات كافيه
للحفاظ على الامن في هذه المنطقه وان لم
تكن كافيه ما الذي تحتاجه هذه الوحدات لكي
تستطيع الحفاظ على الامن في هذه المنطقه
مضيق باب المندب
اعتقد ان القياده المركزيه سبق ان اتخذت
الخطوات اتجاه تامين البحر الاحمر من خلال
تاسيس قوه مهام البحر الاحمر في ابريل
العام الماضي وتركز هذه القوه على الامن
البحري الاقليمي وبناء القدره من خلال
بناء الشركه مع القوه البحريه وخفر
السواحل التابعه لدول المنطقه لتحسين
مشاركه المعلومات والتنسيق فهذه القوه
جلبت معها من سفينتين الى ثمان سفن
ومسيرات بحريه جويه مما يزيد من الوجود
العسكري في المنطقه ويحسن الدرايه
بالاوضاع وقدره الاستجابه في حال وقوع
حادث
لكننا يعني مستر مارتن يعني مؤخرا دائما
ما كانت هناك قوات امريكيه في هذه المنطقه
لحمايه الممرات المائيه المتعلقه بالملاحه
البحريه بشكل اخر لكن هناك بعض يعتقدون
بان الاهتمام الامريكي بهذه المنطقه قد
تراجع هل تعتقد بانه برغم كل هذه القوات
الولايات المتحده ليست لديها الرغبه
الكافيه للالتزام والحفاظ على الالتزامها
بالحفاظ على ان هذه المنطقه
كلها اعتقد ان امريكا لا تزال لديها رغبه
في تامين المنطقه يجب ان ننظر الى الاهميه
الاستراتيجيه لمضيق باب المندب فاي فاي
حديث في هذه المنطقه ستكون له عواقب وقيمه
على الاقتصاد العالمي فمن مصلحه القوه
العالميه كافه تامين امن هذه المنطقه خاصه
مع الولايات المتحده عبر القياده المركزيه
والقوات البحريه المشتركه مصر مارتن ذكرت
القوه العالميه والصين الان يعني يبدو
بانه دورها في منطقه الشرق الاوسط يتصاعد
بشكل كبير سواء على المستوى السياسي او
حتى المستوى الاقتصادي لكن برايك هل الصين
مؤهله للاعب اي دوري عسكري لحمايه او
للمشاركه في حما الممرات المائيه في هذه
المنطقه خاصه بانها مستفيد اقتصادي بشكل
كبير
هذه
البحريه الصينيه نشرت قوه خارجه جيبوتي
وقد سممت بالاصل لمكافحه القرصنه ولكن بما
ان هذا الخطر قد زال فهذه القوه هناك الان
لدعم جهود الامن البحري وفيما يخص تنفس
القوه بين امريكا والصين فهذه منطقه تنفس
في سياق اهدافها الاستراتيجيه الاوسع
فكلهما لديهم مصالح عسكريه واقتصاديه في
المنطقه ولكن التنفس الان ينصبوا على
الصعيد الاقتصادي والنفوذ وليس على القوه
العسكريه مستر مارتن بعيدا عن الصين
وبعيدا عن الولايات المتحده ما هو المطلوب
من دول المنطقه لتنميه قدراتها البحريه
للحفاظ على الملاحه البحريه في هذه
المنطقه خاصه بانها المسؤول المباشر عن
امن هذه المنطقه
يجب ان تركز على تحسين قدرتها الدفاعيه
البحريه والوعي البحري ويمكن ان يتحقق ذلك
بشكلين اولا من خلال تطوير والمحافظه على
قدره مراقبه واستطلاع بحريه قويه وثانيا
عبر تطوير امكانيه العمل المشترك مع
الشركاء الاقليميين والدوليين ولهذا وضعت
قوه مكافحه الارهاب 53 في المنطقه امام
حليا فعلى دول المنطقه التركيز على تعزيز
قدرات حفر السواحل لضمان امني وسلامه
السفن التي تعبر مياههم او تستخدم مرافقهم
مصر مارتن كيلي المحلل الاستخبارات في
مركز الاستشارات الامنيه اي او اس رزق كنت
معنا من لندن شكرا جزيلا على هذه التوضيحه
بعد سلسله من الاختبارات دامت لسنوات عده
نجح سلاح الجو الامريكي في اطلاق صاروخ
فرد صوتيه من علامات نقاذفه قنابل
استراتيجيه الصاروخ اي جي ام 183 والذي
يعرف اختصارا باي ار دا بيبو هذا الصاروخ
الذي صنعته شركه لوكيد مارتن الامريكيه
تفوق سرعته سرعه الصوت بنحو خمسه اضعاف
كما انه يحمل راسا حربيا انزلاقيا يتجه
فور اطلاقه من منصه جويه الى خارج الغلاف
الجوي للارض ليسقط بعد ذلك على الهدف
مباشره يمكن اطلاق الصاروخ من القاذفه
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه الاشهر باثنين
وخمسين كما يمكن اطلاقه ايضا من القاذفه
بي وان والمقاتل الهجوميه اف 15 اي يبلغ
مدى الصاروخ 1600 كم كما يمكن تزويده
برؤوس حربيه تقليديه او نوويه
[موسيقى]
بعد الفاصل الخيار العسكري ضد ايران يعود
للطاوله بعد عوده نتنياهو الى السلطه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اثر التعاون العسكريه
الروسيه الايرانيه قلق العديد من دول
المنطقه خاصه بعد التقارير التي تحدثت عن
عزم موسكو تقديم تكنولوجيا عسكريه متطوره
للطيران من بين هذه التكنولوجيا طائرات
مقاتله حديثه
هذه هي التطورات تتزامن مع توقف الجهود
الدبلوماسيه لمعالجه الملف النووي
الايرانيه وكذلك ايضا عوده التلويح
الاسرائيلي وربما الامريكيه احيانا بوضع
الخيار العسكري ضد منشاه الطيران النوويه
على الطاوله لمناقشه هذا الموضوع وغيره من
الموضوعات معنا القائد السابق للقياده
المركزيه الامريكيه الفريق اول كانت
ماكنزي اولا ااا جنرال ماكينزي اهلا بك
معنا في عسكريتاريا في البدايه كيف تقيم
التعاون العسكري ما بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وحول فيها في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط وما الذي يحتاجه حلفاء الولايات
المتحده في هذه المنطقه وتحديدا في هذه
المرحله الصعبه للحفاظ على انفسهم من اي
تهديدات
معكم اليوم لقد تشرفت خلال عملي في
القياده المركزيه بالتفاعل مع العديد من
اصدقاءنا وشركائنا في المنطقه اعتقد ان كل
دوله من دول المنطقه تواجه خطرا محدقا من
ايران
وهذا التهديد يتمثل في صواريخهم البالستيه
ومسيراتهم الجويه وصواريخ كروز لمهاجمه
الاهداف البريه وبالتاكيد تهديد
الميليشيات المسلحه التابعه لهم عبر
المنطقه اعتقد ان كل ذلك كان له الاثر في
توحيد دول المنطقه بينما يحاولون ايجاد
السبل الفعاله لصياغه استجابه مشتركه في
وجه هذا التهديد الحقيقي والمتنامي
جنرال المكانزي مع عوده رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بينامين نتنياهو الى السلطه
عادت تلويح الاسرائيلي من جديد
بضروره توجيه ضربه عسكريه لمنشئه طهران
نوويه برايك الى اي مدى هذا السيناريو من
المتوقع ان يحدث وكذلك الى اي مدى هناك
قناعه في واشنطن بهذا الخيار الاسرائيلي
يتمثل في ضروره عدم امتلاك ايران سلاح
النوويه اعتقد ان الجميع يتفقون على ان
افضل سبيلين لتحقيق هذا الحل هو عبر جهود
لا تشمل حرب وعبر الحلول الدبلوماسيه لكن
كل دوله لها الحق في كل وقت للدفاع عن
نفسها وهذا يشمل اسرائيل والولايات
المتحده لا اعتقد اننا يجب ان نزيح اي
خيار عن الطاوله خاصه في الوقت الحالي
بينما نواجه هذه المشكله
انكنزي هناك من يقيم مخاطر البرنامج
الايراني للصواريخ البالسيه بانه اكثر
خطوره حتى من الملف النووي الايراني هل
تتفق مع وجهه النظر هذه
انا من بين هؤلاء الاشخاص اعتقد ان سنام
القدرات البالستيه الايرانيه الى جانب
نوعين الاخرين من الاسلحه التي نقشناها
للتو وهي صواريخ الكروز والمنظومه المسيره
وفرت قدرته عاليه لايران عبر السنوات
الخمس الى السبع الماضيه
يمتلكون قدرات كبيره وبامكانهم استخدامهم
هذا التاجيرانهم هذه الليله وليس في مرحله
المستقبل كما هو الحال مع الملف النووي بل
يمتلكون قدرات ان كانهم استخدامها فورا
وهذا الامر مقلق جدا واعرف انه جذب
الانتباهه المباشر لدول المنطقه
حديث الان بانه روسيا ربما ستقوم بتزويد
ايران بمقاتلات حديثه الى اي مدى هذا
الامر ان تم سيضاعف من قدرات ايران
القتاليه وكيف يتم التعامل مع هذا الامر
سواء من قبل الولايات المتحده او حتى من
قبل الحلفيها في المنطقه
الخطيره اعتقد ان هذا التصرف غير مسؤول من
روسيا في حال فعل ذلك ولكن كما شاهدنا فان
روسيا قديره على القيام بتصرفات غير
مسؤوله
وبنطاق يحبس الانفاق فلا شيء تفعله روسيا
سوف يفاجئوني واعتقد اننا قادرون على
معالجه هذا التهديد اذا ما ترى
الجنرال كنزي كيف تنظر اصلا
تحالف العسكري القائم الان ما بين طهران
وموسكو هل تعتقد بانه التحالف قوي قادر
على الصمود ام انه تحالف الضروره كما يطلق
عليه بعض الخبراء
بل وربما تحالف ياس روسيا في مشكله بسبب
حربها العدائيه في اوكرانيا وحقيقه جلبهم
لاسلحه من ايران واطلاقها ضد اهداف في
اوكرانيا يدفعون جميعا لتامليه في ضعف
القدرات العسكريه الروسيه وما يقلقني اكثر
من ذلك بصراحه هو تدفق التكنولوجيا الى
ايران من روسيا هذا الامر مقلق جدا سبق ان
تحدثنا قليلا عن احتمال تزويدهم بالطائرات
المقاتله وكذلك هناك احتمال لتزويدهم
بالمكونات المتقدمه التي بامكانها تعزيز
قدراتي صواريخهم البانيسيه والقدرات
الاخرى المقلقه لنا جميعا هذا امر مقلق
جدا لنا جميعا الجنرال المكانزي في اكثر
تصريح اثنيت على القدرات الدفاعيه لعدد من
دول المنطقه لكن برايك هل القدرات
الدفاعيه التي تمتلكها الدول المنطقه اا
الان في هذه المرحله هي قدرات كافيه لردعه
اي تهديدات ام ان دول المنطقه بحاجه الى
مزيد من القدرات الدفاعيه
لقد حفظنا على ما سميته بوضعيه ردع
المتباينه منذ سنوات عديده وقد تمكن لها
من منع العديد من الهجمات من قبل دوله
ايران واوكلائها ومنعنا ايران من استخدام
المنظمات الارهابيه لتحقيق اهدافها اعتقد
ان هذه الوضعيه لا تزال قائمه ولكن دائما
هناك اشياء بوسع من القيام بها وعلى شكل
خاص في مجال الدفاع الجوي والصاروخي اذا
من دلعت حرب في المنطقه في ستكون حرب
صواريخ كروز وصواريخ البالستيه والمسيرات
الجويه وبالتالي فهذه امور علينا لاستمرار
بالعمل على تحسينها مع اصدقائنا وشركائنا
في المنطقه ليس فقط فيما يخص اسلحتهم
وقدراتهم بل كذلك في اسلوب المشاركه
المعلومات ومقربه مشكله بشكل جماعي جنرال
ماكنزي كنت تشغل القائد القياد المركزيه
اثناء الانسحاب الامريكي من افغانستان
والان هناك مع عوده الجمهوريين للسيطره
على مجلس النواب بدء تحقيق فيما يتعلق
بالمشاهد الفوضويه للقوات الامريكيه التي
حدثت اثناء الانسحاب اذا سالت بشكل مباشر
جنرال ماكينسي ستقول من المسؤول عن هذه
المشاهد
بلاي ستيشن قرار انسحابي من افغانستان كان
قرارا سياسيا اتخذته القياده الوطنيه
للولايات المتحده ولذلك فهي تتحمل مسؤوليه
ما حدث بعد اكثر من عام من الانسحاب
الامريكي جنرال ماكينز هل تعتقد بان ما
حدث كان خطوه صحيحه ام لا
مساله الانسحاب اوصيت بعدم مغادره
افغانستان بشكل كامل وقد تسنت لي الفرصه
لتعبير عن هذا الراي ولكن قرارا مغيرا
اتخذ وهذا هو اسلوب عمل نظامنا وانا
اختلفت براي معها واعتقد ان قرار المغادره
واخراج كل شيء بسرعه اسهم بشكل مباشر في
انهيار افغانستان والاوضاع التي حدثت في
اغسطس وكل ما حدث منذ ذلك الوقت في
افغانستان
لكن الان ومنذ عوده الطالبان الى السلطه
تنام ظهور هذا التنظيم من جديد هل تعتقد
برايك بانه تنظيم داعش من المفترض او ربما
يعود من جديد ليشكل نفس الخطوره التي
شكلها في السابق قبلها سواء في افغانستان
او حتى في سوريا او العراق
خرسان في افغانستان لا تزال لديهم الرغبه
في دعم هجمات خارجيه واقصد بذلك هجمات ضد
اراضي الولايات المتحده وربما ضد حلفائنا
وشركائنا الغربيين وكذلك شركاؤنا
واصدقائنا في المنطقه لا تزال لديهم هذه
الرغبه سواء كانت نابعه من افغانستان او
دول اخرى في المنطقه وما يمنعهم من القيام
بذلك هو ضغوط مكافحه الارهاب الفعاله من
قبل القوات المحليه بمساعدتنا عندما يكون
ذلك ضروريا ولا يوجد الكثير من ذلك في
افغانستان اليوم الفريق اول كانت ما كنزي
القائد السابق للقياده المركزيه الامريكيه
شكرا جزيلا على وجودك معنا
قبل تطور سلاح المدفعيه وظهور القذائف
القادره على تدمير تحصينات العدو كانت
الجيوش تلجا الى اشعال النيران في المواقع
المحصنه للعدو لاجباره على الخروج منها
عبر مع عرف بقذفات اللعب قذفات اللهب سلاح
كان له دور بارز خلال حروب عده في التاريخ
العسكريه رغم ان استخدام سلاح قادي في
اللهب يعود الى القرن السابع الميلادي الا
ان تطويره جرى بشكل فعلي على يد
الامريكيين والبريطانيين والالمانيا لعبت
قادفات اللهب دورا بارزا خلال الحرب
العالميه الاولى خاصه فيما عرف حينها بحرب
الخنادق والتي كانت تتم فيها محاصره
الجنود داخل مخابئهم تحت الارض السخدمه
قادفات اللهب بشكل كثيف وفتاك خلال الحرب
العالميه الثانيه خاصه بعد ان تم تعديلها
وبات مدارس
بريطانيا والولايات المتحده فبات تستخدم
قاذفات لهب كبيره وكانت قادره حينها على
بث نيرانها حتى مسافه تصل الى 140 متر
وكانت فعاله جدا ضد التحصينات والمواقع
الدفاعيه من ابرز عيوب قاذفات اللهب انها
كانت تشكل خطرا على حاملها بشكل كبير بحيث
كانت عرضه للانفجار في حال اصابتها بطلق
ناريه
لهذا الاسبوع قد انتهت الاسبوع المقبل
المزيد من الاسلحه والمزيد من الصفقه في
امان الله
[موسيقى]